vous avez dit tout à l'heure que votre
valeur ajoutée c'est de réaliser des
expertises sur des enjeux complexes ce
que vous nous avez dit dans vos propos
alors bon je sais bien que le métier
d'enseignant est un métier très
difficile notamment
dans ce moment de crise épidémique avec
lala colis de 19
mais je pense justement que se sont ils
ont démontré que c'était des experts on
maintient en matière d'enseignement or
vous avez obtenu un contrat d'un montant
de 496 1800 euros
pour je cite
évaluer les évolutions du métier
d'enseignant d'enseignants vous pouvez
nous dire à quoi aboutit cette mission
oui parce que moi-même la rapporteure
c'est un nous avons été sollicités dans
le cadre du contrat cadre de la dtp par
le ministère de le part le mystère de
l'église plus mystère de l'éducation et
par la déité paix et notre rôle a été
d'accompagner la dtp pour organiser un
séminaire qui était prévu par le
ministère on vient avec son
d'organisations internationales pour
réfléchir à quelles étaient les grandes
tendances d'évolution de marché
des évolutions du secteur de
l'enseignement que les évolutions si
attendu de marché d'enseignants et à ce
titre qu'elle pouvait être les
réflexions autour du métier d'enseignant
nous avons accompagné la dtp dans cette
restriction et nous travaillons
maintenant madame la rapporteure depuis
une vingtaine d'années aussi sur
l'analyse de l'évolution des systèmes
d'éducation
réponse est un peu imprécise quand même
de ce que c'est c'est un sujet
tu pourrais être un sujet d'ampleur
le contrat n'est quand même pas
c'était une somme assez conséquente
quand même donc ça aboutit à quoi
précisément
ça a conduit madame la rapporteure
l'ensemble de travaux qui ont été
réalisés avec à la fois la dictée penja
l'éducation donc il s'agissait d'une
part de travaux de benchmarking de
comparaison de plays avaient été les
évolutions faites à un somme de pays
européens pour anticiper les évolutions
du métier d'enseignant bien analysé
également quels étaient les évolutions
du système éducatif forcément de
pilotage du système éducatif pour
l'ensemble des pays européens et donc
réfléchir à un certain nombre de thèmes
de réflexion qui était prévue pour la
tenue d'un séminaire avec les les
responsables enseignants qui était prévu
en février 2021 madame donc il y avait
des responsables
des enseignants
c'est collaborer oui madame la
rapporteure mais je n'ai pas directement
piloté ces travaux le pilote l'ensemble
du secteur et j'ai des collègues qui
sont spécialistes de ces problématiques
des boulistes renseignements madame la
réponse d'accord merci
[Musique]